A matrix such as this one will be extremely helpful
when we have even more variables than those in the pseudo-Facebook
data set. Examples arise in many areas, but one that
has attracted the attention of statisticians is genomic data. In these
data sets, they're often thousands of genetic measurements for each
of a small number of samples. In some cases, some of
these samples have a disease, and so we'd like to identify
genes that are associated with the disease. In the instructor notes,
you'll find a data set of gene expression in tumors. The
data contains the expression of 6,830 genes, compared with a larger
baseline reference sample. Now, this is a ton of data. So
let's go ahead and read in the data set, and then
I'll change the color names of the data set to be
the numbers from one to 64. Now, I'm just doing this
so that way the plot that I create is going to be
a little bit nicer with the labeling on the x axis.